Oh
you don't even know my day right now I
was having lunch with Becky so I have
some news
Dale asked me to marry him Oh same no
we're all gonna have to be in this
wedding now
Silver Lining we're gonna get to throw a
bachelorette party we're gonna get to
dress up and be cool it's gonna be just
like fall you're having ice cream in our
suite after the rehearsal dinner and
then we're gonna party right like like
like oh yeah it's just that I'm not a
big partier anymore I'm so glad you're
here
you two know each other from high school
since I was your age I I'm gonna go sit
down
Trebek E and a look at these people
that's a Jane Austen novel can Jenna
sing Oh
Oh tell me she can still wear that
there's got to be something you can do
here
this is housekeeping now Project Runway
well you call bachelorette party without
a bride sorry babe
busted it's like you guys caught us in
route to a gentlemen's club are you sure
you're gonna get in cuz I don't see any
gentlemen here can you relax am i doing
I like to see you man up it's like a new
what you want what do I want you want
someone to put you in your place
yeah I really hate weddings
a missing Katie and Jenna I guess we
found Katie thank you you wear my
pajamas like a Michael Jackson